also happening now metro police still on
the scene of a deadly shooting in the
central part of the valley this happened
just after seven this morning
near maryland parkway and bonanza that
is where bianca holman is live right now
with what may have led up to that
shooting hi bianca
said a metro they say a clerk at a
nearby convenience store
called 911 about a shooting and so when
police arrived they found a hispanic man
in his 20's injured
he later died at unc according to police
the man was walking on nearby 11th
street
he got into a fight what's unclear is if
the person the man was arguing with was
in a vehicle or walking
homicide lieutenant ray spencer says
after being shot the man ran
and went to the 7-eleven asking for help
store clerk there was a citizen who
immediately rendered aid
and along again with the clerk there
were two clerks inside
who called 911 prior to police arriving
so right now we have
the it's a community group called trauma
intervention program
they are out here providing assistance
to the clerk obviously who was shaken up
for
what they witnessed
lieutenant spencer says they're speaking
with people who live in the area and
looking for surveillance footage to find
the shooter metro says if you know
anything about this situation you're
asked to call crime stoppers you can
remain anonymous
and there is a reward for anyone who can
help lead to close this crime
reporting bianca holman 8 news now